[Music]
welcome back to cbs this morning we
continue to follow the very latest on
the breaking news from florida overnight
shocking video shows the aftermath of a
deadly
partial building collapse part of this
condo complex building came crashing
down around two
this morning we're told at least one
person is dead
and at least 10 others are being treated
but there is still
a lot of debris to sift through this is
a residential building located along the
water on collins avenue and surfside
as we mentioned at one point a child was
rescued from the rubble of that fallen
building
an eyewitness described that moment to
our station wfor was yelling please
don't leave me so we tried to stay with
him and then i used my phone to flash
the the light on my on the back side of
my phone to signal a fire and rescue to
come over
so he was just he was just really
panicked he said that his mom was
in there with him you know his arm was
pinned
it there wasn't really a whole lot of
conversation it was just like i said it
was just
sheer panic you know he his mom we
couldn't hear her
couldn't see her so we didn't know what
status that she was in
he just you know please don't leave me
so i told him we're right here
we're not going to let you you know be
by yourself
as we've said there's so much police and
rescuers don't know at this point for
more on this unfolding rescue operation
we're joined now by former miami-dade
fire chief dave downey chief good
morning thank you so much for being with
us
good morning thank you for having me
chief you got 37 years
in search and rescue you went to the
world trade center you went to hurricane
katrina
can you tell us what these search and
rescue teams are dealing with right at
this moment
well this is obviously a devastating
event and uh
the the first responders you know are
all trained
at different levels the initial
responders would get in there
and start doing the surface removals
getting those that are lightly trapped
and assisting them out of the building
i was talking to some of the on-scene
units stairs were
compromised so a lot of those that
weren't injured had to be taken out via
the
aerial ladders that you see on the news
there
as those lightly trapped get removed
then we start moving in with our
technical search people to do the
the the audio and visual and run the
the dogs the canines to look for those
that are trapped in void spaces
that's what's going on right now uh and
removing those that are trapped in any
any void spaces and all the while
uh being aware of the possibility of a
secondary collapse they're still
building this there um so they're still
cognizant of the fact that part of this
more of this building could still come
down hey chief downey
it's tony decouple the mayor of surfside
in an earlier interview with our manuel
bojorquez
said that they had sent the dog dogs in
already and as the mayor put it they
didn't get any hits
no hits from the dogs what does that
tell you
well the the the dogs the hit means that
dogs are trained to find
live survivors and so they
are looking for those scents um the the
initial run
sometimes doesn't reveal anything uh
then they'll get into more specific
runs of the canines they're continuing
to run the dogs
they're a vital element of our search
and rescue operation
um and so they'll continue to run those
dogs and check for any
uh areas of interest uh and and uh
act on those and chief downey jerica
duncan here i think the fear
the biggest fear is the uh enormous
amount of life that could have been lost
in this but
at this point again with all of your
experience do you have any idea
what may have been a possible cause of
this collapse
no it'd be truly speculation um they're
going to rule out every cause
that could be possible looking at the
utilities looking at the structure
itself
uh that'll be something that comes way
after this rescue operation
that's going to be the focus right now
chief uh you mentioned the
the concern about the possible further
collapse uh
what the mayor told us was about a third
of that building came down
uh is there a process that that these
the teams are going through right
now in terms of trying to determine
whether the rest of the building is safe
what's happening there absolutely so as
part of the search and rescue element
uh and keep in mind miami-dade fire
rescue
hosts one of the national search and
rescue teams one of the 28 national
search and rescue teams
that elements of that team are already
on scene including structural
specialists engineers
this is what they do they look at
structures and figure out
where can we work where can't we work
what areas need to be stabilized
in order to work um and they're
incredibly uh efficient and experienced
in what they do
so this is going to be a long term
process because there's going to be
areas that are going to need to be
stabilized so that the rescuers can get
into that
because the last thing we want is any
any more collapse or any more injuries
or loss of life
yeah and as again as the mayor said 100
units in that building former mayor
miami dade fire chief dave downey chief
thank you again for joining us this
morning
thank you for having me